certaines prisons provinciales au Canada
comme celle de rivière des Prairies à
Montréal n'abritent pas que des
criminels on y retrouve aussi des
migrants détenus pour des raisons
administratives liées à leur dossier
d’immigration je trouve ça terrible
c'est avocate représente des migrants
écartés
aux mains aux pieds ils ont vraiment des
conditions comme des personnes qui sont
là au niveau pénal criminels il y a pas
de différence c'est ce qu'a vécu celui
qu'on va appeler Alex pour des raisons
de sécurité se demandeur d'asile
déboutés à accepter de ce confier un
micro fermé ils m'ont demandé d'enlever
mes vêtements de me pencher d'y Alex il
dit avoir subi plusieurs fouilles à nu à
la prison de rivières des prairies avant
d'être renvoyés dans son pays d'Europe
de l'Est où nous l'avons joint
Alex qui souffrait de problèmes de santé
mentale à passer six mois derrière les
barreaux même s'il n'était accusé
d'aucun crime selon un document de la
Commission de l'immigration Alex a été
détenu en isolement dans une cellule
très très petite il n'y a pas de
toilette dans la cellule il y a un trou
dans le sol j'ai des clients qui
m'appellent en pleurant en disant
qu'est-ce que je fais ici comment je
vais m'en sortir l'emprisonnement de
migrants pour des raisons d'immigration
contrevient aux droits international
selon de nombreux avocats experts des
droits de la personne pourtant environ
2000 migrants sont incarcérés chaque
année dans des prisons provinciales un
peu partout au Canada y compris au
Québec on demande aux provinces de
résilier ses ententes là
où dirige la campagne bienvenue au
Canada qui demande aux provinces de
mettre fin à leur contrat avec l'Agence
des services frontaliers du Canada pour
l'emprisonnement de migrants récemment
la Colombie-Britannique et la nouvelle
ont décidé de résilier leurs ententes
mais le Québec l'Ontario le
Nouveau-Brunswick l'Alberta et la
Saskatchewan les maintiennent pour
l'instant c'est extrêmement choquant
c'est même outrageant que l'on puisse
traiter des êtres humains de cette
façon-là dans un pays comme le Canada
pour sa part l'Agence des services
frontaliers dit qu'elle utilise les
prisons provinciales en dernier recours
seulement ici Brigitte bureau
Radio-Canada Montréal